alors les autorités disent avoir abattu
la majorité des drones qui ont attaqué
au dessin et sa région comme d'habitude
je pense que c'était 12 d'abattus sur 17
qui avait été annoncé sur au dessin à la
dernière nouvelle selon les réseaux
sociaux au dessin il y aurait d'autres
drones au-dessus de la ville à l'instant
où je vous parle des drones de
surveillance estiment les habitants qui
essayent évidemment de comprendre
qu'est-ce que c'est exactement les
autorités affirment que plusieurs
frappes ont touché un objet
d'infrastructure appartenant à l'État
sans toutefois préciser exactement si
c'était le port sur le port ou un autre
objet d'infrastructure ça c'est la
pratique en Ukraine il donne pas des
détails sur qu'est-ce qui a été touché
exactement mais ils admettent qu'il y a
des dégâts
un mot également de blessé selon les
autorités Gulliver un mot également de
la Crimée Crimée annexée en 2014 par les
Russes d'après le Washington Post la
Russie veut y construire plusieurs
kilomètres de tranchées est-ce qu'il y a
des réactions ou même des confirmations
depuis chez vous
il y a des images satellites qui ont été
publiées montrant les tranchées qui ont
déjà été creusés cela ne date pas d'hier
en réalité depuis le début de cette
invasion à grande échelle la Russie
renforce ses défenses en crimées et
selon plusieurs sources ils font de plus
en plus ces dernières semaines les
Ukrainiens estiment que la Russie
considère comme réellement possible une
attaque de la part de l'Ukraine sur la
Crimée pour reprendre le contrôle de la
péninsule que la Russie a annexé
illégalement en 2014 et c'est
l'intention affichée de l'Ukraine
volodiumski le président ne cesse de le
répéter il n'est pas le seul au
lexidanilove le chef du Conseil de
sécurité nationale de l'Ukraine a
récemment publié son plan pour ce qu'il
faudra faire avec la Crimée après la
reprise de cette péninsule par l'Ukraine
et il parle même d'expulser toutes les
tous les Russes et ils sont je pense
environ 400 000 qui ont élu domicile
dans la péninsule depuis l'annexion donc
depuis 2014 c'est une politique assez
radicale mais les Ukrainiens estiment
qu'ils ont absolument en droit de le
faire puisque c'est leur territoire qui
a été annexé illégalement il y a
vraiment vraiment un très très grand
différent entre les Ukrainiens ici qui
pensent vraiment qu'ils sont capables de
reprendre la péninsule et leurs alliés
hier Mike Pompeo l'ex secrétaire d'État
américain était à Kiev pour afficher son
soutien à l'Ukraine vraiment il était là
pour montrer qu'il était le républicain
qui soutient le plus l'Ukraine aux
États-Unis et même lui n'a pas osé
répondre à des questions sur la
possibilité de reprendre la Crimée par
la force il a dit cela va être très
difficile etc clairement les Américains
et les autres alliés de l'Ukraine
hésitent beaucoup à l'idée de soutenir
l'Ukraine dans cette tentative de
reprendre la péninsule peut-être
justement à cause de ces défenses que la
Russie a mis en place qui leur fait
penser que ce sera très très difficile
d'un point de vue militaire merci pour
ces précisions gilaver crack les